good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
thursday we are so close you guys
do you smell that i smell it it smells
like friday she's around the corner we
only got
one more day to make it through before
it's the blessed friday
and for that we have no choice but to be
grateful and you know what else it
smells like
toast a ween tomorrow oh my god yes
halloween toast the favorite day of the
year jackie and i have been working on
something we got a little we've been
cooking it up in our bowl like hocus
pocus
trick up our sleeve and we think you're
really going to enjoy it so make sure
you if you're a podcaster i might want
to switch over to youtube for tomorrow
because it's going to be very visually
pleasing
yes it's going to be some really really
fun stuff
now i heard a very you know
unconfirmed rumor that you have an
announcement to make i have an
announcement to make i've been waiting
like a few weeks to make this
announcement i just wanted to make sure
you know
everything went as planned but my
announcement which most people have
guessed
is that zach and i have gotten a puppy
yes he is the cutest
little man of all time you got him
yesterday we got him yesterday so i
didn't want to say yesterday like
yesterday just in case but i've been
with him for the last 24 hours we've
been vlogging the whole experience
and we are making a video for our
patreon if you want to know how it's
been going
and um can we get a name reveal yes so
you'll you'll see our journey to this
name on the vlog
because it's like 99 confirmed but we're
still
um we're still trying to make sure his
personality matches his name you know
because we don't want to be calling him
something that's just not him
but right now his name is bruno which i
love
me too i mean it's like the perfect name
for zach and i
to name a puppy but i just need to make
sure it's the perfect name for the puppy
for bruno
right so but we've been calling him
bruno i call him bruno sweets
[Music]
i'm actually going over right after this
to see bruno no one has met him yet
i'm just so excited it's gonna bring me
back to my early motherhood days you
know
yeah no he's such a little puppy like
such a little man and he really is
so similar to magnolia and theo
his coloring i'm like i by the time
you're listening to this i will have
posted the photos on my instagram so
head over there
his coloring is the same as theo but
he's a lot more red than theo he's
probably like 80
red 20 white making him like really a
fusion between theo and magnum
hybrid so i think like the three of them
together it's just gonna be cuteness
overload no it's going to be
overwhelmingly stunning for everyone and
i'm just so excited to welcome bruno
into the family i mean
time the family expands we now we're
like a brigade of three dogs which is
just crazy like we're it's gonna be very
hard for us to travel
but i'm just it's such a wonderful day
and i love welcoming
a new puppy to the scene yeah it's just
yesterday was
so special tell me about the moment tell
me about the moment you went to
laguardia
yes we picked him up and he was like so
cute he was obviously like a little
confused a little scared so we were just
like in the car with him
soothing him we brought him into the
apartment and it's been raining in new
york as you can tell it looks like
8 p.m outside it does and so we made
we've made the decision for like these
first few days he's not going to be
leaving our house because i've been
reading this book on cavaliers now that
like zach is all in
on the cavalier life which we talk about
in the vlog because if you've been
following for a while you know that
it took him something he was all out for
a while yeah so we've been reading this
book that just
talks about how the first few days are
very important so we've literally been
like
nesting and just trying to get him
comfortable like walking at his pace
so much little legs like trying not to
carry him everywhere in the house like
letting him
discover the house and so he's been like
peeing and pooping wherever he pleases
and is that your worst nightmare um no
yes obviously it's like our house
doesn't smell like it did two days ago
but it's it's worth it for all the love
that it brings did i not tell you that
no and i've always known that i've just
i'm now good and ready and so
yesterday and i'm just glad to see that
he's peeing and pooping you know like
that right things are working
things are working and so it's it's you
know a constant
work in progress and he has a long way
to go
but we're gonna do the work and i'm
really excited it's the start of a
really just beautiful journey for you
i'm so happy for you and you know what
i feel like some things are just like
meant to be
and your love for theo while i'm so like
i'm going to miss it and it's not going
anywhere but
you have more energy to channel too i
think like i had
too much love for theo like it was
spilling over and like there was nowhere
for it to go
no and it was like at that point like if
you love a dog so much you need one
i know and i've needed one for a while
and i finally have one
it's very exciting and like last night
we were on my bed like reading
the book for the redheads and he was
just like sleeping next to me and it's
like this is what i've been
dreaming of yeah and it's just really
exciting
i'm very happy for you thank you and
he's so cute and i cannot wait to meet
him like i'm literally rushing through
the show
so i could go home and meet him yeah and
he'll be joining the pups with no job
instagram account
it's just going to be like super premium
content per usual he's just like
the cutest man bruno sweets he's tcm the
cutest man
he's the cutest man um well it's just
very exciting and i'm so glad everyone
guessed it
and everyone knew and it's not that i
was like really trying to be like secret
project
it's just like i don't like to say
things before they happen because i just
feel like it's kind of a jinx i'm like
superstitious about you
so it's not that i didn't want to say or
i wasn't excited i just
wanted to make sure like everything went
as planned everything went smoothly
people had some other funny guesses like
some of the guesses i was like i [ __ ]
wish like
people were like no she definitely
bought a house on a farm like in the
suburbs oh yeah
i got a [ __ ] wish oh no now i need to
go do that well now that we have three
dogs like
it wouldn't be right to not get them a
vacation home no i know
i'm so excited for when the three of
them get together like it's not gonna
happen for a while because i
don't want to overwhelm him like i
really want him to just like
be really comfortable um because
i think in the long run it'll pay off in
droves like theo like the most
independent man alive theodore forgeman
and just like
the most perf chairman like it doesn't
get better than theo but i hope you can
get close
no i know and i was reading this book on
cavaliers and how you should like train
them and treat them and
how much dependency versus codependency
and
he it pretty much like spelled out what
theo
went through and like what his journey
has been and like where theo is today is
like the
goal for all the byproducts of all the
work you put in in the first year like
puppy years are so important
yeah so i'm really just trying to do all
of the right things right now and
we're just enjoying our time so it's
been really exciting i woke up super
early
but i think you're about to become like
if it's possible even more of a home
body
yeah no i mean it's not possible which
is why i've
needed a little man yeah and if
i don't i don't want to even put it out
there but if we go into like a wave
three lockdown joy joy to
the world bruno is here
bruno is [ __ ] here
let every pub know
of bruno let theo and magnolia sing
let theo and magnolia sing let the yo
and magnolia sing hey
um so congratulations thank you thank
you
um can i give a little personal life
update sure i
it's kind of a big deal i have recently
gotten into napping
and i wish this was something i really
started like when things were real
locked down because now it's like we're
sort of transitioning back to regular
life and it's like a weird time
for me to be taking up like midday naps
but when i was in college i used to take
like a two-hour nap
every single day it was the best part of
my day and then of course like i got
busy with you know my
bustling career and i just couldn't do
that anymore but i'm now two days in a
row napping yesterday and after get
ready for three hours
and then i went back to sleep like after
dinner like at a very normal time
and it's it's a wonderful thing
especially in these unprecedented times
i think that
naps should really be made a priority
for everyone yeah i've taken like a
handful of naps
in this situation and they've always
been nice they can sometimes be a little
disoriented
and they sometimes like wake up with
anxiety and like i feel my phone buzzing
like through my sleep and it's just like
kind of torture
but when you hit that right nap there's
nothing better
i think what i've really struggled with
during quarantine is coming to the
realization of like how long the days
are there's just so many hours
and when you nap through like three of
them it really makes it go by faster
oh well that too was theo napping with
you
that is a good question i don't know it
was such a deep nap like i don't
remember i want to say no
that would make it just the creme de la
creme i know but i actually don't think
that he was but
when we fell asleep last night like
theo's nose was truly between my butt
cheeks and like
it was amazing like he just happened to
like really just like squirrel
into my ass and i like wasn't mad about
it at all it was like really just a
beautiful moment between mother and son
that's nice maybe like he knew in his
heart and so like he was getting another
cousin and he was like
thank you mummy the people who think
that theo is my human son
are like her kid put his nose up her ass
l-o-l oh also i don't know if i
mentioned this but i have a book coming
out it's called
yeah yeah did you not know no no i
didn't know what that's so crazy
you've been busy with the dog like i
understand mine's been elsewhere let me
tell you a little bit about it it's
called girls in a job
the crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster it's really just like an
overarching 10 chapter book about my
life
my career personal life dealing with the
death of my father body image meeting
ben
breaking into comedy cancel culture a
lot of really interesting things that
even if you listen to this podcast or
you're a patreon member and like you
know everything about me
there's so much more to know i'm just
like a constant you know
source of knowledge and information and
the book yeah it's available on amazon
for pre-order um
pre-order's actually really important
for authors especially first-time
authors
because you know uh at certain retailers
like barnes and noble it's really hard
to get on the shelves
but if you have very strong pre-order
numbers pre-order hardcover
kindle any format ebook um it really
helps you know me get to like the
airport you know and that's like my goal
i'm trying to get to the airport
yeah so girl with no job.com book or if
you just head over to my instagram
there's tons of links in my stories and
the link in my bio
i'd really appreciate any support as
this is my first book and you only get
one chance
to be a first-time author so again
girlwithnojob.combook
really appreciate all the support thus
far it's really been overwhelming that's
beautiful speaking of books i just
finished a book for the redheads we're
recording today
so if you have questions about the book
email there at heads book club by
gmail.com
and for the redhead stands i just want
to assure you like there will be a girl
in the job book episode in january just
in time for the release
and i'm really looking forward to like
diving into it like we don't hold back
no i know and i'm honestly like nervous
i feel like it's like going on the view
for books no
it is the view for books and you will be
the first author that we've ever
invited on the show you know what's so
interesting is how we always talk about
here like how we like
label ourselves like are we influencers
are we podcasters
and it's like my whole life has been
leading up to like i'm an author
yeah and i think that's how i'm gonna be
addressed moving forward you think so i
think i'm gonna have to get my phd
i mean doctor no job dr faceman
yeah he has his phd he's actually
getting a haircut today which is his
favorite time of day oh my god that's
when he's the best in the biz
truly his groomer uses the most amazing
expensive shampoo i think it's called
like le pooch it's like literally so
expensive
and i went to buy it once like because i
give theo baths like
not as in-depth as she does but it was
like so expensive and i'm like
you're using tresemme like get in the
bath but yeah but when she does it it's
like a real treat you know
wow that's exciting i can't wait to see
him whenever i do yeah
for that special moment and hopefully
we're hoping that bruno and theo can
meet
maybe this weekend we'll see where his
disposition's at let's take that let's
not rush
you know we have a lifetime ahead of us
i know very exciting
very exciting so with all the excitement
behind us i think it might be time okay
let's go to get into the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true and i i would be silly
to even argue with that so
let's leave it at that okay well first
of all everyone is talking about the
bachelorette claire crawley's decision
to not be the bachelorette any longer a
bachelorette executive
went on nick vials podcast and people
are raving about the episode
and is spilling some tea truly so
abc's entertainment rob mills appeared
on the
former bachelor nick files podcast on
wednesday where he acknowledged that
producers knew from the start
that claire's season would be
unpredictable not this unpredictable
however he said he said it became clear
that claire's season couldn't continue
on as usual when she decided to not give
out a rose at the end of a group date
that did not include dale choosing
instead to give the rose to herself
at the time it was sort of controversial
he said this was the time when we
started thinking
oh my god like we've really got to start
thinking about this when she didn't give
out that rose and just gave it to
herself
nick said i felt like i saw that coming
it's like dale's not on the stage i'm
not just not going to give a rose
and mr mills said right that was it that
was it and that was when we started
making the call
to pivot right yeah i mean to
i feel like part of me is like
yes it was very obvious that the season
couldn't go on but i know that the
producers of the bachelor like make
people do things all the time and part
of me thinks they could have just like
made claire pretend for the rest and
like just edit it all together
to like a shitty season which i'm
actually glad that they didn't do but
like there was a way to make this work
yeah they have forced people to do worse
then so say she didn't give it to anyone
and then they were like no claire you
have to go give it to someone like all
of those guys would have been
especially whoever got it would have
been like oh [ __ ] this but they
when you've shown us that no but like
you could feel morale like yes
at a certain point like people there's
only so much movie magic you can do
yeah and you know morale has been like a
really interesting concept on the show
because i feel like
because everyone was quarantined for six
months they were more excited than usual
to like start
the season so we only started like we
started at a record high morale in
bachelor like history
and we've also achieved a record low
yeah also i feel like if they had
continued the season like any time she
went
on a one-on-one date if she's so in love
with dale and thinks he's her fiance
like
she probably wouldn't have kissed anyone
else yeah so then we're only seeing like
these makeout scenes of her and dale and
she's not kissing anyone it's like what
like also the viewers you know yeah no
there's only
so much you can get away with and i hate
when you can tell when a season is so
heavily edited
some are much more edited than others i
think like in recent history the most
edited one i remember was nick viles
how like we felt so confused remember
that volleyball date where like half the
girls went home and they like never even
addressed it it was so edited it was
meant
to protect i think vanessa rimaldi in
the editing because they didn't want her
to be the villain because then she ended
up winning
and i feel like they had something to
prove like when they they didn't want
nick to come out as a bad guy because so
many people were like nick sucks because
of like the whole andy dorfman drama
so i'm actually glad that we were spared
like such a like
over overtly edited
season because it's confusing and it's
exhausting and i hate feeling like
there's something they're not telling us
yeah and i'm so excited for tasha yeah
and this has made it like extremely
dramatic really like the most dramatic
in a while in a while chris harrison's
words are ringing true
also some interesting tea um that mr
mills shared i can't
for the life of movement because his
first name robert mills
shared was that um krishell stouse was
considered for the bachelorette over 10
years ago
as was she ever a contestant no he said
i actually had lunch with chris this was
about 10 or 11 years ago to talk about
being the bachelorette
eventually it wound up being deanna um
who was
the girl spoke to claire he said there
was a time when bachelorette was sort of
done just like every so often when they
decided to do it
he said a casting director recommended
stouse who was on all my children for
the gig
oh and they weren't just picking
contestants they were just picking
people yeah
he said we had this incredible lunch i
think it was at the beverly hills hotel
and she was awesome and i was convinced
i'm like this is the bachelorette
however there was a big push at the time
to give the role to deanna papas one of
the two women sent home
by brad womack in the season 11 finale
got it
even ellen called abc to recommend her
crochet
deanna which is why it went to deanna
wait what is ellen's involvement
i don't know he she just like felt
really strongly that it should be her
can i say like that this week's episode
was the first time i'd ever heard the
name deanna and like i've been watching
the bachelor forever
well now that i hear like i agree but
now reading like deanna pappas and
brad the brad womack i didn't watch that
season but now it's all coming back to
me
it's not even remotely ringing a bell
and her face didn't ring a bell either
when she sat with
um claire but i actually think she gave
some pretty good advice
yeah honestly christelle would have been
amazing on the bachelorette like she's
so
bachelory like she's so eligible when i
was watching her on the show i'm like
she reminds me of everyone from the
bachelor
yeah like that really she could have
gone down that road and like still ended
up being
exactly where she is yeah totally except
for like the justin hartley part oh yeah
but that was like the worst part of all
the things she's accomplished that's
like not even the coolest one you know
selling sunset dancing with the stars
but i don't think she would have been
there without
the marriage it would have been a very
different situation
honestly i feel like she could still be
in the bachelorette yeah she's in the
abc family now with dancing with the
stars yeah and she's single
and she's beautiful and she's like
bachelory yeah
there's something i don't know if it's
like the haircut the makeup the fox
like there's that look yeah she is the
look
yeah so i just thought that was
interesting this sounds like a very
interesting podcast episode
yeah for anyone looking for bachelor tea
which is like a lot of people
next story a little unhappy couple news
brad pitt and his girlfriend nicole
patrolski have broken up
isn't she like 11 is she no
he's 27 she's 27. okay brad pitt and
german model nicole patrolski have split
page six has learned
the couple who were spotted together in
august are totally over according to a
source
it was never all that serious as it was
cracked up to be the source said
we're told the breakup happened a while
back how old is brad pitt
56 and she's 27. yes so that is
more than double right just wondering
i'm not being judgey i'm just genuinely
like is the math
27 times 2 is 52.
and how old did you say it was 54. and
how did you say 56.
so yes okay more than double i was just
i'm not being shady i'm just like
genuinely
i'm curious you know i have a curious
girl i'm so into like digits
it's crazy on the one hand i want brad
pitt to like be in love forever
and be in a relationship that makes him
so happy but on the other hand like
i don't know that i thought that this
was like end game no i definitely did
not think it was end game and i don't
know if i really
see like a long-term relationship for
brad pitt i feel like he was in back to
back
jennifer aniston uh angelina jolie and i
feel like now he just wants to get like
not to be disgusting like he just wants
to get his dick wet you know and his
freak
on yeah and i'm okay with that like his
kids are grown and
i feel like it's not a midlife crisis
because he's like already accomplished
so much and like his family life
and i just feel like he's like over the
drama of like tumultuous relationships
and i i'm here for whoever he wants to
bang like i really am
i don't know i think at a certain point
maybe we're nearing that point like he's
gonna want real companionship
yeah and i do think at some point like
he might go back to jen like i really do
feel that way i know the internet would
like literally implode and like [ __ ]
itself
but and i don't even stand them
necessarily even honestly when he broke
up with her i was like so team angelina
but and i was also seven years old at
the time um
i don't i don't like ship them so hard
but i do think there's a very strong
possibility that like they get back
together
i don't think at all and not now but
soon
i don't think so i mean i think i'll
have a substantial relationship but i
don't think that that's the one i still
and i don't think that she would ever do
it even if she was dying to i don't
think she would
oh i 100 think she would like literally
two [ __ ] seconds
no like that's just
no i just think that she like literally
would drop everything to go be with him
wouldn't you i don't know i mean yeah i
would but after what he put
her through i don't know if i like my
dignity i know but also at the end of
the day it's like did he actually put
her through a lot or was it just like
literally dramatized in the tabloids for
over 10 years
no no i think he put her through a lot
and it was dramatized in the table right
over 10 years
it's literally still on the cover of
every like supermarket magazine but i
haven't been to a supermarket in so long
i was just thinking about that i love
the supermarket i know i need to go i
need to like see what's new in
like the food aisle yeah but with all
like the delivery options it's just like
it's so easy not to go but when i get my
groceries delivered and i'm like
shopping online like i can't think i'm
of course place myself in the store
i need to visualize it i'm literally
ordering from my previous order i'm like
just refill my card
i wasn't happy with my previous order
either no i know when i and then the
food comes and i'm like
where is the food like it's literally
just like water
and rice cakes like and where is the
food no i totally agree that's why you
need to go to the supermarket to get
inspired
yeah but i don't live near any
supermarkets it's probably the one
downside
of like i love my apartment and i love
everything about my building in my area
but the closest supermarket it's like a
couple avenues over which is a [ __ ]
far walk especially if you're carrying
groceries
so um that's a struggle and that's why
i'm using
i don't know how we went from talking
about brad pitt to grocery stores but
um oh yeah grocery store tabloids but
i'm just saying like i
i love grocery stores and you know what
i really love
non city suburban grocery stores oh my
god of course you could get all your
steps in like a publix
is thickening heaven on earth thickening
the public seafood
a key food sickening yeah but in the
city
like fairway is pretty legit fairway is
actually incredible
treats it depends on which location
though because some of them when they
don't have a lot of real estate
they're built linear so it's like an
escalator with your car
yeah no and it's like all the the aisles
are like curvy it's like [ __ ] tetris
but the one on 32nd and 2nd is truly a
dream
yeah that's a nice place to be because
they've got some sweet treats that are
like
you want to eat you know unlike trader
joe i mean i guess people like trader
joe's but i just feel like everything
there is
healthy no i know but then it's not
because then they have like jingle
jingle
and all of these things that you see
that go viral and it's like sweet treats
like maybe i should go to trader joe's
something about trader joe's like it's
good if you need something but like to
have your whole
apartment like to be stocked from trader
joe's is so bizarre to me because they
don't
sell like name brand there's no like
nabisco there's no poland spring it's
just like trader joe's brands
which is cool for them but something
about it feels like very like hallmark
movie where everything is like fake
do you know what i mean prop food yeah
no i don't get that vibe but i can't
explain the vibe that i do get because
it's like not whole foods but i do sort
of categorize them together you know
they're definitely similar but i think
whole foods like
carries products from other brands not
the most well-known brands
like annie's right whereas like trader
joe's is like
trader joe's mac and cheese like they
don't have brands
i don't think so i think they do no not
really like they literally have their
own brand like for everything
but it's the same product yeah but it's
just like the obsession with themselves
at trader joe's like that's what i find
bizarre got it
so yes in the city i would definitely
rank fairway as the number one grocery
store in this group
and then i think i would go morton
williams yeah but morgan williams is
just like
standard and so small yeah you're not
gonna find any like
new discoveries there actually before
morgan williams i would probably put
like the last few
dying dagostinos no no no yeah i loved
agastana oh
no no no but yes not living near a
grocery store is really hard so that's
what i was trying to say
and brad pitt wishing you the best of
luck in your romantic endeavors yes and
speaking of romantic endeavors adele is
saying that she's single
after she's been linked to the rapper
skeptum
and i'm not so i'm feeling skeptical
yeah so the other day people were saying
adele had a new man
the british rapper skepta but then
yesterday she posted saying happy
halloween i'm going back to my cave now
to be the single cat lady that i am
peace out till next year
so it felt like she just wanted to let
us know that she said cause she could
have made
the sentiment on her caption like the
same without like going out of her way
to
say that she was single right also the
single's in parentheses so it was like
single she's she's telling us she's
singled out single yeah and maybe it's
because she heard like brad pitt was
single so she's like trying to keep her
options
but you know what i know that's what i
was gonna say next that's not the most
like that actually makes a lot of sense
adele and brad pitt like you would never
think it but now that i'm seeing them
together
i feel like brad pitt obviously like
loves a beautiful woman and adele is
stunning but i think he also really
values like
someone with like a nishama you know
like a soul like a
great spirit about them and i've never
met her but what i get from adele is
that not only she likes so inherently
talented it's like
she has a type of magnetic personality
that people just like want to be around
she's like hysterical
but she literally could have made it as
a comedian or a model but she like
just happened to be like the most
incredible singer in the world like i
feel like she has that type of magnetic
energy that brad is really looking for
yeah i i hope that someone sets them up
on a date
me too i don't know who adele is friends
with jennifer lawrence
and i feel like jennifer lawrence and
bradley cooper are friendly yeah
and that might be how we get them
together they have to get the gang
together
yeah like a like a game night or
something oh my god that was just adele
definitely loves games
yeah yeah i hope adele is out there
playing the field it sounds like she is
if she's being linked to someone but
then saying she's single like she's
letting all the other men
on the bench know like no no like
there's other like right you're not
special you're still in the game
so i just hope that she is having a
great ass time
me too i like get so mad when i think
about what adele has like been through
because
she had to give her uh ex-husband like
70 million dollars
because like yeah she gave literally
half her fortune i think of something
because of like the british
rules on like community property i don't
know what it was but like i don't know
why like that just makes me mad
yeah i didn't know that it makes me mad
like she literally bared her soul toward
for years like worked so hard
and like here we are just like forking
over 70 million dollars to the man who
broke her heart
no no but you know what like she
like she'll be fine that situation has
given her probably the fuel to make
another 70 like that
100 like one more album in tour march
you're fine
but it's just upsetting yeah for sure
okay
next story kylie jenner admits to
feeling sad about having to hide her
true personality so kylie uh joined
james charles on his youtube channel and
she admitted to feeling sad about not
being able to show her
most authentic self she said i think
that i showed my true personality for so
long ago on vine and instagram
but as i got bigger and bigger i
realized when people used to say really
mean things about how i really am
my personality and what i loved the most
about myself it would hurt me more than
almost playing a character
she said so i just started doing a
little less which is sad it makes me sad
james pointed out to his fans just how
witty and funny kylie is to which she
responded
you saying that that's a bigger
compliment to me but it's something that
is so
sacred i feel like this is something
that has we've
spoken about a good amount like hashtag
who is kylie jenner who is kylie jenner
and
i think now she's in a place where she
shows a little bit of herself but enough
like to keep us happy and
and a little enough to keep her
protected
right like if you followed her on social
media and like watched her content
you would think she's like this dud
because she really just doesn't share
that much like about who she is
but what i find so interesting is that
she's like this deeply complex
interesting like personable person
and she really doesn't let people show
that and she still managed to literally
become the most successful like
young entrepreneur because of social
media without ever really showing us who
she was
and i feel like in addition to some
other reasons that's maybe why she
doesn't
go on keeping up definitely because even
like the snippets we got of her this
season like in palm springs there was so
much personality that jumped off the
screen we got a whole new song
i just finished a whole cup of 42 and
i'm about to go for my second one
courtney what the [ __ ] are you on
so i just feel like she gives
she might have to give too much of
herself to be on the show in addition to
like all the other reasons why she
doesn't do it
but that starts to make a little bit
more sense
yeah and there when when her snapchat
was like super popular and she has she'd
already become so famous
she like was in her house one night with
jordan woods and they were like being
crazy like sitting in the pantry eating
cereal
and she was like it was the most
personality we'd ever really seen from
her and she was like
this is like the real me you guys
hashtag who is kylie jenner and it was
just like so
sad but it was really true that we never
saw that girl again yeah and maybe she's
now popping out in this
james charles video you know yesterday i
did say that i thought she was pregnant
and i still stand by that but she did
drink in the video
and her instagram stories have been
showing like a lot of like you know
mid-drift region but i still stand by it
um okay and i looked into it like i said
that i would
and i don't think that she is but she
did open up in the video about her dream
to expand her family
she said i want more so bad i actually
think about it every day i just still
don't know when
i'm not planning i don't have a time for
that to happen
i don't know so she definitely wants
more kids claude thinks she's having
them now
i don't think she's pregnant but we'll
find out soon enough i guess
i feel like a lot of them could be
pregnant i think chloe could also very
possibly be pregnant
and i don't know what people are
thinking that courtney and scott are
like back together back together and i
do think courtney would have another kid
so
okay i don't think chloe's pregnant
either and i think courtney and scott
are the same courtney and scott that
we've always seen i think the picture
that they took on the beach like is a
picture that they could have taken even
when scott was dating sophia and like
nothing has changed
i think one of them's pregnant and i
think it's kylie but we'll see
i really don't think any of them are i
do but they'll let us know when they're
ready
if they are i do
they'll let us know when they're ready
yeah no and i'm going to speculate until
then
oh wow okay i thought we were done doing
that no never oh my god no i literally
think like you've said like we need to
stop like asking women like no did i ask
them i'm just speculating
okay fine do what you gotta do yeah i'm
gonna give them the space and time that
they need
okay you're so much better than me fifth
and final story a little new tv show
news that sounds pretty good
the masked dancer might be even wilder
yeah i know the mascara dancer might be
even wilder than the masked
singer craig robinson is said to host
fox's the masked
eyes [ __ ] love craig robinson with a
group of panelists
you will never be able to guess honestly
they
are an interesting group of panelists
but i approve so if you there's a show
called the mascara
dancer who do you think would be a judge
like one of the huffs
okay that's a good guess but no jlo no
jenna dwan
no they already have jobs doing that
yeah that's why i'm saying them
like that so is it young people like
new newer not super new uh
dan okay like tick tockers no dancers
establish celeb dancers
like they're literally i don't think you
would you might be able to guess one
wait i really want to guess hold on boys
or girls two boys two girls
huh two boy dancers no
no these are not dancers the girls are
dancers yes and one of them
is a big dancer a bd
a bd like very established in the
industry has done this kind of work
before
oh my god i literally the only person in
my mind is julianna half like
who paula abdul okay i literally would
have never guessed
her and the other woman is ashley
tisdale
and show sounding worse and worse and
the two men
are ken jung and brian austin green
excuse me yeah your favorite guy oh my
god
this show just went from actually being
something i would potentially watch just
because i
i absolutely adore craig robinson i
think he's actually one of the funniest
comedians like of our generation and he
doesn't get enough credit
first of all second of all this panel of
judges
like each name was more disgraceful than
the next i actually think the only
person that i don't hate
is ashley tisdale well isn't ken jong a
a
singer okay so that him coming over
makes this the masked dancer
i'm here for that i guess but like and
he's shown that he has
judging chops i think the one who makes
the least sense is brian augustin great
1 000 this is really bizarre like
who it should literally be charlie
damilio like they want this species
that's what she would probably be like a
mask dancer
yeah but you need to have some like uh
star power on your panel
i mean honestly the the panel for masked
singers pretty good robin thicke nicole
scherzinger
jenny mccarthy even though she's not a
singer but like i don't know
i think that tv shows like really need
to start hiring like
gen z and millennial consultants because
i don't know what they're doing over
there but like
this was like a decent not even a good
like a decent idea that was
really squandered like let us help you
okay this is this could have been great
no it's just fine and
it's just bizarre here's the description
of the new series the mexico
dancer will feature celebrity
contestants shaking their tail feathers
while covered from head to toe in
elaborate costumes and face masks that
sounds like
very technically challenging and by the
way i always think it's hard to sing on
the math singer in those huge things
can you imagine like shaking your ass i
literally would go into heat stroke
leaving audiences to guess their
identities costume celebrities will be
joined on stage by mascara partners
and backup dancers
as they perform a series of dances
together spanning from hip hop to salsa
jazz to tap dancing and more
when it comes to dance styles the sky is
the limit can we talk about some of our
favorite
failed competition shows sure you know
which
what was one that like really made no
sense the four
oh yeah that was [ __ ] weird like but
they got
good judges oh i thought they got really
good singers
both meghan trainor was a judge p diddy
dj khaled hosted yeah and charlie
walk who it's like a big music industry
exactly but i think he was brought down
in the me too movement
so maybe that was like the demise of the
show there was a fourth one right
because they're the four
oh that is what they would be yeah i
guess i could just do a swift google
i really missed the days of x factor i
think that was the perfect reality show
and to be honest if there's a voice a
singing competition show and simon
cowell isn't involved
like i'm not interested okay here's the
team
on the four um sean diddy combs and dj
khaled and meghan trainor were panelists
and fergie was a host and they obviously
um
cut charlie walk out of that description
because
he was the little man on the end yeah he
was like the you know the token the l.a
yeah the simon cowell right ellie reed
was on x factor
there was just a time where x factor was
like literally the cornerstone
of my day like that first of all that's
where i discovered fifth harmony
remember carly rossan and claire
there was so many so much goodness b
miller right
and she's actually pretty big um but
then there was also like the amazing
judges demi lovato was a judge britney
spears was a judge
they were paying them like 30 million
dollars for like 10 episodes it was
crazy
yeah but there was x factor really never
hit that big here here
but fifth harmony did like yeah well
because they just you know the creme the
cream always rises but like
it's so big in the uk and isn't that
where we got one direction susan boyle
yes or that might be britain's got
talent
no i think it was x factor okay you know
what i don't watch either is america's
got talent no
me neither but it's not for any
particular reason i actually
think they always pick great hosts they
went from nikken and tyra and now terry
crews who i love
um i'm just like not interested in
seeing people's talents if it's not
singing
like yeah no like dancing and like
juicing cats and like
mission to me like it's like a fourth
grade talent show
and that's literally what it is
america's got talent and the singers
always
rise and they always usually win yeah so
that's why i don't like america's got
talent but they're just over the years
been so many random
like competition like singing or just
like talent shows that
i love to take a walk down memory lane
yeah i don't really watch that many i
guess it's just not my format
except for shark tank and
songland such a brilliant show brilliant
both are so brilliant both have like
taught me so much about industries that
i really did not know much about that's
actually true especially about shark
tank like the nature of entrepreneurship
yeah entrepreneurship mexico dancer
entrepreneurship yeah yeah um and as
they say on shark tank shark tank has
ignited the entrepreneurial spirit of
america
it's mad true and i feel like before
shark tank if you said you were an
entrepreneur it's like oh you're
unemployed
and now it's like oh either you're
unemployed or you're like very
successful and just that like balance
has really done wonders for the
entrepreneur community
i agree no like it's not as much of like
a sad word anymore like it actually has
some weight to it
and that's because of people like mark
cuban and damon and all those
wonderful guys and the crew and the crew
they're back actually they're doing like
socially distance episodes i haven't
watched yet
i haven't watched either i go in like in
phases you know and i don't like to
watch one episode on hulu i need like
four yeah so i just like to binge
speaking of tv the real housewives of
orange county was on last night and i'm
just like really excited to announce
that i didn't watch it and i'm excited
to announce that i knew that claudia
wasn't watching it so i didn't watch it
and instead i finished my book and then
i
treated myself to an episode of queen's
gambit oh my god i watched one two
one also the one after she finally gets
to paris oh i'm not there
she just left las vegas oh she's so
like determined you know who she reminds
me of and i know no one's gonna feel my
call
wait but she is reminding me of someone
so i'm hoping you can nail it because my
calls are based on mind body and spirit
as you know
um and she reminds me of kendall jenner
what no people you'll see it soon not at
all but it's such a good show i treated
myself
and the reason why i didn't watch real
housewives of orange county last night
is because i've really just been
prioritizing
sleep and once you listen to your body
and your body says like we cannot watch
this trash we need to go to sleep
it's such a mind-blowing experience and
i
really i implore our listeners to
prioritize sleep yeah and for me it was
like i knew you weren't watching and i
needed to finish my book so like that
was the priority but then when i did
have a little bit of time i was like
with bruno and i'm like
i don't want him to judge me for the
trash that i watch no
you're walking welcoming him into your
home and you're gonna show him gina like
honestly no that would be setting a bad
example
right so instead i was like let's learn
a little bit about chess
oh yeah see that's the kind of i firmly
believe like the the culture and the
media you put around your children like
really has an impact on them you are
what you watch right now i feel like
theo was
really born on like friends and that's
why he's such a friendly person
that's so true i'll have to figure out
like what bruno's
likes likes and dislikes are going to be
so
i'm gonna watch at some point we'll just
restart our ocd caps next week i'm not
in the mood to like recap tomorrow
okay like that's just pathetic if it was
a good show maybe
but also kardashians are on tonight and
also like i haven't heard anything about
the episode like
me neither so i think we're okay sorry
so we'll just pick back up next week
and kardashian recap tomorrow which i
will be watching i'm actually going over
my friend anna's house tonight
and she's cooking dinner and she's such
a good cook like i'm really looking
forward i'm gonna go over like stretchy
pants and no makeup and just like
feast and then sit on her couch and
watch kardashians wow that sounds so
amazing
i'm recording redheads and then i'll be
getting home and getting my little man
i'm going to meet the little man oh he
hasn't ever seen kardashians he's going
to love it oh he
definitely feels like the type of man
who
appreciates strong successful women
strong successful and beautiful women
and
he himself i i think is going to grow up
to be beautiful stunning
and smart yeah it'll be so wonderful to
like watch him grow and see what he does
with his life
okay we need to wrap the show because i
forgot i'm going over to bruno's place
and i'm gonna get to meet you for the
first time so
if you want to see what bruno looks like
head over to my instagram head over to
pups with no job
he's just the cutest little man and um
i'm just really excited for this journey
for myself
we are here at the toaster so excited we
will support you this is obviously
a you know we provide free day care for
all of our employees here at the morning
toast so bruno is always welcome here if
you need to
you know change his diaper or anything
like this is a very safe
space for you i will bring him to the
show maybe next week i'll see how he's
doing
like on an adjustment level so we'll see
him on the show
soon but not too soon and then
eventually once he's in a rhythm like
he'll be a staple just like just like
his cousin thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we are also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have ready to catch box all the places
even amazon music now
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us in the morning toast leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
don't forget tomorrow is toast to ween
make sure you are subscribed to us on
youtube
it's gonna be an episode you're not
gonna want to miss so don't forget that
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye